die illegale elfenbein jägerei hat
drastische folgen durch die wilderei
kommen mittlerweile ein drittel der
afrikanischen elefanten ohne stoßzähne
auf der welt denn die nachfrage nach
elfenbein in asien ist groß hier denkmal
unsinnigerweise immer noch dass die zu
pulver zerriebenen horner eine art
wunder medizin gegen fieber und so
weiter sind ein krasses und trauriges
beispiel dafür wie wir menschen in der
evolution herumpfuschen können ihr habt
euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht
und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts
so herzlich willkommen bei pixum science
and fiction
und wie er zum whatsapp und den anderen
messengern kommt und direkt kontakt mit
mir aufnehmen können das erfahrt am ende
des videos das ist wirklich ein
schlimmer irrglaube der von 2007 bis
2014 alleine 144000 afrikanische
elefanten das leben gekostet hat die
mehrheit der chinesen weiß tatsächlich
nicht das elfenbein von getöteten
elefanten stamm viele asiaten denken die
elefanten hörner würden den tieren
abfallen wie bei kindern die milchzähne
ausfallen hinzu kommt dass das horn das
zu pulver vertrieben wird noch immer
eine entscheidende rolle in der
chinesischen medizin spielt aber auch in
vietnam wird es von vielen vor allem
reichen leuten genutzt beispielsweise
als anti kater mittel oder als aufputz
strobe dabei besteht es hauptsächlich
aus keratin genau wie unsere fuß oder
fingernägel hier also doch die stoßzähne
erfüllen wichtige funktionen für die
elefanten sind quasi die oberen
schneidezähne die im ersten lebensjahr
die milchzähne des elefantenbabys
ersetzen fanden können mit ihrer hilfe
beispielsweise die rinde von bäumen
schaben nach wasser oder wurzeln graben
und natürlich gegen andere elefanten
kämpfen
im laufe des elefanten lebens werden die
stoßzähne immer länger und dicker und
dennoch gilt elfenbein in asien als
luxusprodukt und wird bei schwarzmarkt
preisen von bis zu 50 euro pro gramm
gehandelt naturschutzorganisationen den
seit jahren gegen diesen irrglauben und
das unwissen der menschen an aber
dennoch hat wilderei spuren hinterlassen
in mosambik waren bis 1992 fast 90
prozent der tiere ausgerottet
bei denen die überlebt haben und sie
vermehren konnten kommen nun aber ein
drittel der elefanten ohne stoßzähne auf
die welt und das liegt an dem
evolutionären druck unterschiedliche
forschungsgruppen konnten verstärkt
feststellen dass immer mehr elefanten
eben ohne die veranlagung für stoßzähne
geboren werden denn weil besonders
diejenigen unter ihnen die große
stoßzähne tragen gejagt und getötet
werden können sich diese elefanten nicht
mehr fortpflanzen dafür aber diejenigen
die kleine stoßzähne haben oder gar
keine
und dieses merkmal geben sie dann auch
an ihre nachkommen weiter und das obwohl
die wilderei in mosambik mittlerweile
ganz gut unter kontrolle gebracht werden
konnte und sich die elefantenpopulation
erholen konnte denn auch nach dem ende
des bürgerkriegs
1992 sind es 30 prozent der weiblichen
elefanten die ohne stoßzähne zur welt
kommt und dieses phänomen ist nicht nur
in mosambik sondern auch in anderen
ländern zu beobachten und das hat fatale
folgen für die entwicklung der gesamten
elefantenpopulation denn studien zeigen
dass die großen elefanten die meist auch
die größeren stoßzähne tragen
normalerweise deutlich mehr kälber
zeugen sie werden bei der fortpflanzung
von weiblichen elefanten eigentlich
bevorzugt denn sie tragen wohl besonders
gute gene zum überleben in sich so lange
sie nicht gejagt werden natürlich ein
trauriges und krasses beispiel also für
menschen gemacht der evolution und
darauf sollten wir als alles andere als
stolz sein ein weiteres beispiel dafür
ist übrigens die intensive selektive
fischerei
nicht nur dass die weltmeere schon bald
leer gefischt sein könnten
forschungsteams haben schon vor einiger
zeit festgestellt dass dadurch nicht nur
die anzahl der fische sondern auch ihre
körpergröße und ihre
fortpflanzungsfähigkeit schrumpft auch
hier also der mensch als evolution
faktor der vor allem die starke fischten
fischarten stark und schnell
beeinträchtigt die populationen können
sich nur sehr langsam erholen weil immer
kleinere und weniger fruchtbare fische
überleben
die kabbala bestände von neuseeland
beispielsweise haben so den druck ihrer
energie viel früher in die fortpflanzung
zu stecken als normalerweise über
lebende fische werden genetisch bedingt
also früher geschlechtsreif und bleiben
so auch kleiner hier ist das bekannte
darwin prinzip der evolution nachdem die
stärksten überleben also tatsächlich
umgekehrt die besten überlebenschancen
haben die kleinen und schwachen ja
manche forschungsziel sind da der
ansicht dass diese entwicklung durch die
elfenbein jagd und die fischerei
möglicherweise bereits unumkehrbar sind
und der grund dafür sind wir menschen
nicht umsonst gibt es einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die die folgen des menschlichen
verhaltens und handels mit den fünf
größten massensterben der erdgeschichte
vergleichen
ja wenn er als erstes neues zur
evolution und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp oder den anderen
messengern wie instagram facebook oder
telegramm dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantieren ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von links zum
mitmachen und mitbestimmen was hier bei
pixum passiert und zur begrüßung habe
ich ein kleines goodie für euch einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken evolutionstheorie endgültig
bestätigt kreationisten auf verlorenen
posten ja so ist es ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran